dr strange's trailer has just been
released and we now know who the main
villain is gonna be it is an extra
dimensional entity a ruler of a hundred
universes and it is a giant monster
which actually fits perfectly in our
channel but there is a dilemma here
marvel studios term it as gargantus
which sounds kind of like a suicide run
replacing the actual fun for something
bland so this is the same trailer that
was seen in the end of no way home shown
as a post-credits scene so without any
further ado let's reveal who the hidden
villain monster of doctor strange
multiverse of madness is so subscribe if
you haven't and now let's get down with
the sickness
firstly let's discuss a little bit about
a trailer
we start with some spell that was scarce
that causes the instability of
space-time and that doctor strange says
the multiverse is a concept that they
know nothing about we then hear two
voices one of doctor strange
and one of baron model and he seems to
confront dr strange about the spell that
was scarce in no way home and that
causes such a break in the threat of
reality we then see a series of clips
which shows chaos and strange in an
alternate reality where they where the
city of new york is in pieces strange
then goes to wander for help and they
both with miss america enter another
mirror dimension to figure things out
then there are scenes of confrontation
with baron motto and then a giant
tentacle master who is the crux of the
topic in this video was seen and lastly
we see that the main threat was actually
another version of doctor strange but
that's a little bit too bland isn't it
there has to be something more behind
this and we believe that the technical
beast is more than what is shown
so who is this villain this is a monster
with one big central eye multiple
tentacles and the same reddish green
color scheme as the old classic doctor
strange antagonist called schumacherath
and it looks exactly like the original
description of it as seen in the trailer
although in the movie artwork the
monster is named as gargantus which is
another monster altogether and is
defined largely as a mindless creature
lacking schumacher's multiversal power
and evil intelligence which raises the
question will marvel downgrade a top gun
evil entity like schumer garath who is
capable of causing an upheaval in the
multiverse to a small unknown gargantus
before we come into any conclusion let's
discuss whether shima garath and
gargantus have appeared in marvel before
the first shimmer garath is the ruler of
a hundred dimensions
and came to earth millions of years ago
ruling the earth and feasting on ape men
it has been seen in issue 1 of journey
into mystery volume 2 and many of
marvel's premiere issues it has appeared
on earth since the prehistorical times
of the highborn age and even as late as
the present times whereas not much is
known about this gargantus and it was
seen in just one issue that is number 13
of the submariner and at that time it is
a sea dwelling creature and not at all a
threat to the multiverse
so let's look at schumacher's
description and powers
this monster was a powerful omnipotent
and ancient demon who wielded tremendous
supernatural powers and was dubbed the
archetypal class 3 demon by some which
means he's the top of the top
he is thought to be one of chaos primal
powers he was regarded as the most
powerful one of the old ones and he is
practically unstoppable in his native
dimension given his previous
reformations it is unclear whether he'll
ever be completely killed
he is even said to be more powerful than
mephisto and omamu which they both
stated themselves his skin is rubbery
and almond and often appears as a scaly
being with six to eight tentacles and a
great central eye which was also seen to
have pincers claws and insectoid limbs
in addition to a large fang mouth his
powers are beyond measure even more than
that of dormammu himself
so why do we think that he is the actual
main villain and not doctor strange from
another universe or this so-called
gargantus well let's take a look from
our point of view daughter strange as
some sort of villain has already been
seen in an episode of what if and in it
he becomes the most powerful entity in
his universe even ending that universe
by his actions so what's the point of
setting up another similar story
moreover we also see wanda the scarlet
witch and she is one hell of a ride by
herself but she has in the past coming
issues been mind control by another
worldly creature or other worldly
entities so with her power revelations
in one division this becomes even more
deadly if you stop and think about it
that she is now manipulated by another
all-powerful being like shuma garad
and the same goes with doctor strange
from that other universe the one that he
actually failed to stop shimagarath and
is now some sort of herald for the big
guy
sort of like how the silver surfer
ushers in the coming of galactus
and that in the movie baron murdo
actually meets the darker strange and
thinks it is who the actual strange from
that universe would turn out to be in
their reality
therefore shimagarath would actually be
the one behind it all the tentacle beast
in a trailer also mirrors an earlier
comic issue where an avatar of
shimagarath wreaks havoc on earth but
due to its limited powers as it isn't in
its true form it is banished so that's
what we think
and if you have your own theories then
let us know oh yeah gargantus
he's just that nothing more than a typo
i believe
so i hope you have enjoyed watching that
video anyway with it we come to the end
of it so do hit that like button for
support and subscribe as well to be a
part of the mind cue family
but most of all
do smash that bell icon for regular
updates on new videos when we post it
right here on this channel
till the next one
take care fam